foreign
happy Wednesday I got the day right
okay here we go good afternoon everyone
yesterday the president addressed the
wave of tragic and senseless shootings
we saw over the holiday weekend in
communities Across America including
shooting shootings in Philadelphia Fort
Worth Baltimore Lansing Wichita and
Chicago
our White House team has been in touch
with State and and local officials
in many of these communities and the
President also had an opportunity to
speak by phone with the Baltimore mayor
yesterday the President also marked one
year since a shooter armed with an AR-15
style weapon fired upon a crowd of
Americans gathered for an Independence
Day Parade in Highland Park Illinois
and he highlighted how in in the year
since Illinois governor
JB pritzer Highland Park mayor Nancy
rotary legislative leaders and numerous
Advocates and gun violence survivors
have fought tirelessly to ban assault
weapons
like the one used in Highland Park as
well as high-capacity magazines across
Illinois but as we have seen over the
last few days there's a there's a lot
more a lot more work to do to address
the epidemic of gun violence that is
tearing up our communities tearing it
apart
President Biden is doing everything in
his power from enacting historic gun
safety legislation last summer to two
dozen executive actions to combat the
epidemic of gun violence Across America
but he also knows that that is not
enough which is why on the heels of the
tragedies we saw unfold across the last
few days the president continues to call
on Republican lawmakers in Congress to
come to the table and ban assault
weapons in high capacity magazines
to require safe storage of guns to end
gun manufacturers immunity from
liability and to enact Universal
background checks lives are at stake
here folks lives are at stake in
communities the lives of our kids
and these are meaningful meaningful
Common Sense reforms that the American
people support majority of the American
people support these reforms and we need
Congress to do something we need
republicans in Congress to do something
to protect our communities
now on a brighter note I wanted to share
some good news from Monday that may have
gotten lost because of yesterday's
holiday you might recognize this chart
on my left here from when NEC director
lail Brainerd visited the briefing room
very recently just about a week ago it
shows construction of manufacturing
facility has increased by nearly 100
percent in two years adjusted for
inflation on Monday we learned that the
boom continued in May
as the Wall Street Journal put it this
is America's Factory building boom due
in no small part to the chips Act and
the inflation reduction Act binomics is
unleashing huge private sector
investments in manufacturing with
businesses investing more than 490
billion dollars in manufacturing and
clean energy since the president took
office including more than 11 billion
dollars in South Carolina where as you
know we will be there tomorrow the
president will be there tomorrow to
announce manufacturing investment
republicans in Congress again including
every Republican representative from
South Carolina want to threaten these
Investments jobs and economic
opportunities by repealing repealing the
inflation reduction act which actually
helps the American people
but as the president said at his first
inauguration he is the president for all
Americans it doesn't matter if you're in
a red state or a blue State and his
agenda helps all Americans so tomorrow
announcement will be proof of that and I
hope you all get to join him on this
trip with that Josh good to see you good
to see you
two subject areas person has the U.S
been in contact with the Kremlin over a
possible prisoner exchange for Wall
Street Journal reporter Evans convention
but um
Josh I wish I could stand in front of
you and say that we have news to share
on Evan sadly we do not have any news to
share what I can say is uh Evan along
with Paul Whalen who are both wrongfully
detained as you know should be home they
should be home with their families I
just don't have anything to share at
this time
and secondly for the entry go to the
holiday
can you give any more details on where
the Secret Service found the cocaine in
the west wing and how income so as you
know this is under the preview of The
Secret Service they are currently
investigating what happened over the
weekend so I would have to refer you uh
to the secret first the Secret Service
on all of this but one thing that I can
share that I'll that I'll share a little
bit or more information as you know the
the president and the first lady and
their family were not here this weekend
as you all reported on this and as you
also know that they left on Friday and
returned just yesterday
where where this was discovered is a
heavily traveled area where many White
House West Wing I should be even more
specific of West Wing visitors come
through this particular area I just
don't have anything more to share it is
under investigation by the Secret
Service this is in their purview and so
we're going to going to allow uh
certainly the investigation to continue
and we have confident that the Secret
Service will get to the bottom of this
go ahead
said hey let's get to the bottom of what
happened here well I mean I just said
that we have confidence that the secret
service is going to get to the bottom of
this as you all know the president
follows all the reporting here and he
certainly was briefed by his staff on
everything that we know so far but the
Secret Service is investigating this is
investigating what happened over the
weekend we have confidence that they
will get to the bottom of this is there
still a chance that Sweden will be
approved by into NATO by the time of
next week's Summit so look this is
something that the president as you know
the Sweden prime minister is here
they're currently meeting as we speak
right now in the Oval Office as some of
your colleagues maybe yourself Steve was
able to was able to uh be in in the Oval
Office so look I mean we've been very
clear on this we've uh We've encouraged
turkey and Hungary to approve Sweden's
application for NATO a membership as
soon as possible and Sweden and I said
this last week I've said this many times
has fulfilled the commitments they made
under the trilateral random of agreement
they had agreed to win to two with
Finland and turkey on the margins of the
NATO Summit in the in Madrid just last
year about a year ago Sweden is a strong
capable defense partner that shares
NATO's values and will strengthen the
alliance and contr and contribute to
European security and so we believe that
this should occur that their partnership
into uh them to become members in NATO
as soon as possible and that's what
you'll continue to hear from the
president I think uh the Sweden prime
minister being here today having a
meeting with the president certainly
shows that commitment
I think screen just two quick follow-ups
uh you said the president has been
briefed on the cocaine that was found at
the White House is the White House
conducting its own internal
investigation this is something that's
under the purview of the Secret Service
they're the ones who handle this
investigation so it lives uh in in their
purview in their world and then just a
quick follow-up on this type of tour can
you explain to the American people who
would have access to the West Wing on
this type of tour and what kind of
Protocols are in place so look when it
comes to a security protocol that's
something that the Secret Service
certainly is going to handle and so that
is a question for them when it comes to
when it comes to visitors to The West
Wing they come for many reasons
obviously we do have West Wing tours
that that occur here on campus they
happen in this particular past a couple
of days they happened on Friday they
happened on Saturday and Sunday the
times that they do not happen is when
there's a Federal holiday like yesterday
there was not a West Wing tour and also
when there's a white a large White House
Event so I don't have anything more to
share on on the particulars again when
it comes to security when it comes to
anything of those types of protocols
that is something that secret service
handles
eventually
[Music]
[Laughter]
incoming president
I wonder if the cocaine episode has
prompted the White House to ask the
Secret Service to review its security
protocol our minister is coming in so
let's go let them do their investigation
again this is under their purview let's
see exactly what occurred and what
happened they're get going to get to the
bottom of this day meaning the Secret
Service not going to get ahead of of any
changes in protocol or anything like
that let's let the Secret Service do
their job which we believe and have all
the confidence that they will get to the
bottom of this episode kind of shines a
light on the fact that you can bring in
illegal substances into the White House
so what's preventing a visitor from
bringing in Anthrax or something that's
not magnetic into the White House no
look I totally understand the question
but it is under investigation we're
going to get to the bottom and to
exactly what happened the Secret Service
will not us and so we're going to let
the secret servers do their job I'm just
not going to get ahead of of if or or
whens or changes we just have to let the
sick good service do their job which
they are you're welcome
can you just tell us how the White House
is assisting the Secret Service with
this investigation have you made any
White House officials available for
interviews with law enforcement for
example well look we're not assisting in
anything this is under the Secret
Service purview this is their uh their
kind of guidance and guideline their
their world and so we're going to let
them do their job we are not involved in
this this is something that the Secret
Service handles under their protocol and
they're going to investigate and get to
the bottom of what happened this weekend
and we appreciate that and you know that
this is an area where visitors on tour
groups often pass by so is that the the
working Theory right now that it was
likely a visitor and are you confident
that this was not a White House staff
there is investigation they're going to
get to the bottom of this what I want it
to be very clear is that this is a
heavily heavily traff heavily traveled
to be more accurate area of the campus
of the White House and uh and it is
where visitors front to the West Wing
come through this is the part where they
come through when it comes to coming to
the West Wing I just don't have anything
else I'm not going to speculate on who
it was but just wanted to make that very
clear and give you all a little bit more
information I believe the Secret Service
is also sharing this as well
other topic
among the 12 Palestinians who were
killed in the Janine operation carried
out by Israel four were under the age of
18. Israel says that all the
Palestinians who were killed were
combatants does the White House have an
assessment
of whether they were indeed all
combatants or whether any civilians were
killed so here's here's what I'll say
um you know we as you all know and we
have said this many times we support
certainly Israel's security and right to
defend its people against Hamas
Palestinian Islamic Jihad and other
terrorist groups it is imperative to
take all possible steps to protect
civilians from harm and measures need to
be taken to improve the humanitarian
situation on the ground and restore
critical services like electricity and
water to the civilian population and so
don't have anything more to share beyond
that but certainly we are certainly we
are monitoring things very closely you
can tell us about the level of
Engagement by U.S officials to try and
prevent a broader escalation I mean
we've already seen Rockets fired from
Gaza we've seen this uh attack that was
carried out in Tel Aviv
what's the White House doing to prevent
this from us so you know Israel is a
close Ally and partner and we are in
touch with the National Security and
certainly the defense officials so don't
have anything to read out on our
conversation but we are in regular
contact
let me go to that go ahead thanks Karine
I wanted to ask about this decision we
saw yesterday in Louisiana on the White
House contact with social media
companies and do I have to have a
response to the judge basically saying
that this is the most massive attack on
Free Speech in the US history so as you
know doj is reviewing uh the decision
the injunction and so I don't want to
get ahead of of what of what uh what
they will uh evaluate and their options
could potentially be so not going to get
ahead of the doj if you're asking me if
we agree or disagree we certainly
disagree with this decision and as I
said the doj is reviewing this so I'm
not going to get ahead of what their
evaluation what options they're going to
potentially take on moving forward and
this President plan to make a direct
appeal to Turkey or Hungary regarding
Sweden's native look I think we've been
very clear I just laid out where our
position has been and the president has
been very public has been very clear
about about Sweden and so I'm just going
to leave it there don't have anything
else to add towards that I think again
having the Prime Minister here ahead of
uh ahead of a of NATO next week I think
is important but the president clearly
has been uh has been very clear about uh
Sweden becoming a member of NATO and so
we'll continue uh continue to be
outspoken about that and continue to be
public about that
I just don't have any calls to read out
at this time but I think you can see by
the president's actions uh and his words
not just actions that he's been uh
pretty uh pretty steadfast on making on
saying that Sweden should become a NATO
member as soon as possible
how does the White House view the Quran
burning in uh in Stockholm and whether
that will affect the NATO negotiations
with turkey
so look uh I'm not going to get into the
negotiations or any diplomatic
conversations from here uh clearly the
burning of the Quran I as you all know
is something that the president would
certainly agree is is uh you know is the
disappointing to see but I'm just not
going to get ahead of any conversations
or diplomatic conversations being had
uh today the Pentagon announced that
it's taking steps to revamp our
classified information is accessed after
uh the peaks of helicopter information
wondering if the White House has been
involved in any of those conversations
and and whether or not
they caught on their steps I don't have
anything to read out on any
conversations with the Pentagon I would
I would I would refer you to them and
that's one uh
I can't are there concerns that an
illicit substance was brought in to the
White House and not detected by security
uh obviously every guest that that
enters the White House goes through
airport-like security I'm wondering if
just generally if there's concerns about
the ability so let's let the Secret
Service do their investigation again
this is under their purview they're
going to look into all the things of
what happened uh over the weekend I just
don't want to get ahead of that clearly
the secret Services uh is in charge of
security on campus and so I would really
refer you to them on this
prosecuted thanks Ohio Governor Mike
dewine is asking the president to
declare East Palestine a major disaster
area after the train derailment to send
the president a letter on Monday is the
president considering and will he
fulfill that request so um I can say
this uh as it does with all of its
requests FEMA it will expeditiously
review the request of this particular
request from the governor of Ohio as
well this is something that we are we do
every time this comes through us what a
couple things I do want to State here as
it relates to Norfolk and it and
Southern to be more specific it's under
a federal order to cover all costs for
cleaning up its mess that it did that
they caused in East Palestine East
Palestine the EPA is making them pay so
that the taxpayers don't have to pay for
their mess and so we've been very clear
about that the EPA has been on top of
that and so when it comes to Norfolk
Southern they have met their terms of
the order to date and they are stiff
penalties if they do not and so epa's
again has been on top of this and so
just don't have anything further but as
we do with every declaration that comes
that comes our way the FEMA's way major
to that and when it comes to Major
disasters they're going to take a look
at this and they'll make a decision
president not made the visit out there
and at this point is he just not going
to he's done a lot of travel in recent
weeks and months so I'm just going to
repeat what the president said he will
travel to the area to East Palestine
just don't have anything to share on
travel or upcoming dates that he'll be
there but the president said it he's
going to go so he will go once we have a
date we'll certainly share that go ahead
Joey yeah thank you if the Secret
Service determines uh the who brought
the cocaine into the White House does
the White House support the prosecution
of this individual I'm just not going to
get into hypotheticals from here let's
let the Secret Service do their job it's
under their purview we are confident
that they'll get to the bottom of it I'm
just not going to get ahead of this
right this time
so Secret Service officials are actually
cautioning that they might not find the
person involved because it is such a
busy thoroughfare so if they don't get
to the bottom of it as you're saying
would the president be satisfied with
Services a busy room and we found some
cocaine but we don't know who brought it
so let's see what the Secret Service
says right there again this is under
investigation don't want to get into
hypotheticals while investigation is
going going uh going on and is happening
at this time just not going to get ahead
of it let Secret Service do their job
work on the white if I work anywhere on
the complex what is the process like for
me if I want to bring can you just lay
out to the extent that you can the
process for you know if I want to bring
in family or friends as somebody who
works here what is do I go to somebody
in the White House do I go immediately
the Secret Service and say Hey I want to
do this like how how does that work so
their specific process I'm happy to
share that with you uh I I want to make
sure I get it right so not certainly
going to lay that out right at this time
but there is a process as one of your
colleagues mentioned everybody does go
through a process to come on to come on
campus they do get vetted they go
through a security process as it relates
to the security piece of it I would have
to refer you to secret service but
certainly someone from my team can
certainly lay out I think some of you
may understand this process as some of
you may not have heart pass and you know
how this all works but just not I just
want to make sure I get this right so
happy to share that with you after the
after the briefing can you bring you the
trick tomorrow sure let's see
as you know the president's going to go
to South Carolina tomorrow he's going to
uh certainly be making an announcement
on the manufacturing
and if that's a layout here of what
that's going to look like give me one
second
I don't have that here we'll certainly
share it with you after the briefing uh
but I mean this all plays into what the
president has been saying which is like
he's a president for all Americans uh
whether you're a red state or blue State
and we've seen a manufacturing boom over
the past two years since the president's
been here and you see that in South
Carolina and so the president's going to
go to South Carolina make an
announcement we shared some of that with
you all already there was some preview
stories that some of you some of you saw
and so the president's looking forward
to uh to doing that but again this is
something that the president has said he
wants to make sure that we build an
economy from the bottom up middle out
that leaves no one behind and when you
think about manufacturing jobs those
jobs are going to be going to be really
important union jobs that going to uh
there that are going to uh you know make
sure that people have have who are
around the kitchen table and now have an
opportunity to really look at their cost
at the end of the month and be able to
have a good job that pays you know 6 six
figures without some of those jobs the
majority of those jobs without a college
education that's important that is what
it means to have equality at the center
of Economic Policy what that is what it
means to make sure that we have we have
an economy that works for all so that's
what you're going to hear from the
president and this is also by nomics
right we've been talking about binomics
since last week and how it's delivering
you look at the data you look at the
numbers you look at the 13 million jobs
that's been created again the 800 000
manufacturing jobs you look at what the
inflation reduction act has been able to
do the bipartisan infrastructure
legislation has been able to do all our
important key parts of the president's
plan and that's what the president's
going to speak to tomorrow
you just clarify for us we're exactly
inside The West Wing
substance was discovered I'm not going
to get into uh specifics or I can say is
when people visit the West Wing there is
an air there is the area of the West
Wing where it is highly traveled and
that is what happens people come through
this particular area is highly traveled
I'm just not going to get into specifics
I'm not going to get into uh
not going to get ahead of the Secret
Service and so I'll let them speak to
that there are a couple of primary
entrances into the West Wing there's the
one with which we're all familiar right
outside of the driveway where the Marine
stands when the president's In The West
Wing and there's another entrance off
West Executive Avenue can you explain
which which entrance we're talking I'm
going to let the Secret Service speak to
that
uh can you explain why you can't explain
it I mean you described it as a heavily
traveled area that's what the secret I'm
just saying with the Secret Service uh
said we got this from the Secret Service
so I'm sharing a little bit more with
you uh from here but again it's under
their purview it's under investigation
they will they will have more specifics
down the road as they are looking into
this we are confident that they will get
to the bottom of this and so I'm just
going to leave it to them the substance
was discovered late on Sunday what's the
latest staff-led tours that happen in
the west wing on a Sunday you know I
don't have the specific on how late the
staff tours uh staff LED tours go but I
can tell you that there was one on
Friday there was one on Saturday it was
on one on Sunday the times that there
are not any West Wing tours is when
there is a Federal holiday like
yesterday or a big a White House a large
White House Event I just don't have the
specifics let's let's let the Secret
Service get to the bottom of this
they'll have more hopefully more
information and we have confident that
they will be able to figure this all out
so I'm going to give them the space to
do that
excuse me as you've now been referring
multiple times to this investigation
into the White House's confidence that
they will get to the bottom of it I'm
wondering if you could be a bit clearer
about what exactly the scope and mission
of the investigation is and what exactly
getting to the bottom of it means is
this simply a fact-finding mission to
determine whether a potential security
protocols were either insufficient or
violated in this case or is this with an
eye towards potential criminal
prosecution of an individual who's
bringing a banned substance into the
west wing and would there then be
consequences either for that individual
or a if they were a guest of a White
House staff for that stuff so look the
second part of your question is
speculation and I'm just not going to
get into speculation from here what I
can say is again Secret Service is
looking into this they're looking to
what happened over the weekend I'm just
not going to jump into speculation as to
what what their investigation will find
and what we will do or what will happen
just not going to get into speculation
from here as it relates to this district
judge ruling about social media and the
injunction thereof can you speak to the
frequency of contacts that house
officials or Administration officials
more broadly have with social media
companies and the types of content that
they would be flagging and how much is
this a blow to the White House's goal of
preventing the dissemination of
misinformation so look I can't speak to
the amounts that contact has I mean that
is just not a possible thing to do from
here what I can say is that doj again is
reviewing the injunction and they're
going to look into uh you know evaluate
our options so just not going to get
ahead of that and so I'll just leave
that from here okay
um will any White House staffers will
anyone have Snappers the undergoing drug
testing as part of this
so as you know
um uh again this is under the purview of
the Secret Service but a couple of
things that I would add is that white
house is subject to rigorous guidelines
that include drug testing and so we will
take any action is that is appropriate
and warranted pending the outcome of the
Secret Service just not going to get
into hypotheticals from here but uh you
know this is something that when it
comes to drug testing certainly we take
that very seriously and so there's our
they are indeed rigorous guidelines here
at the White House there was a story in
the New York Times over the weekend
about Hunter Biden's daughter in
Arkansas
uh does the president acknowledge this
little girl as his granddaughter I don't
have anything to share from here
okay great thanks
um yesterday Ukrainian president
zelinski mentioned that um so that they
have intelligence that the Russian
military has placed objects resembling
explosives on the roof of The Apparition
Power Nuclear Power Plant is the
president monitoring this
um has he spoken to zielinski and could
it possibly impact his troops
so um
just a couple of things we are
continuing to monitor uh the conditions
at the power plant closely this is
something that clearly we've been doing
for some time as we've said before when
you know Russia's continued military
occupation of the nuclear plant is
dangerous and when it comes to nuclear
plant there should not be fighting there
and so we've been very clear but I don't
have anything new or specific on the
recent reports or anything to share at
this time I don't have any calls any
recent calls to president zielinski the
president is looking forward to going to
the NATO Summit as he will be doing next
week and certainly we'll have more to
share on the details of that trip
thanks screen uh actually following up
on that there's a there's a movement on
Capitol Hill uh to pass legislation that
would uh state that any nuclear fallout
including from uh damage to the
separation due to the power plant would
be treated as uh uh would trigger
Article Five of NATO if that Fallout
were to go over NATO territory do you
support that though I'm not going to
speak to that particular Bill what I can
say is we continue to monitor the
situation we don't have anything new or
anything specific on recent reports that
you all are certainly reporting from the
president but just don't have anything
new to share so we're going to continue
to Monitor and we've been very clear
we've been very clear that Russia's
occupation of this plant is dangerous
and there should not be fighting near
this plant we've we've said this before
we've been very clear about this and
we're going to continue to monitor
to mention that folks from the boy has
were in touch with local officials over
shooting so the past couple days and you
mentioned machine with Fort Worth do you
know who was in touch with Fort Worth
officials so as you know we have the
intergovernmental Affairs my team my my
colleagues here and certainly they are
usually regular touch with local
officials I don't have any names
specific to share with you at this time
but the White House we have White House
offices that are regularly in touch with
what's going on on the ground it's
including the intern in the our
government
intergovernmental Affairs team here at
the White House so that continues to be
the case and then just lastly on the the
cocaine that was found uh following up
on Tyler's question
one thing that you're not expressing is
concern over the fact that this was
found on the property and I guess I'm
wondering how expressing concern would
somehow get ahead of us a secret service
investigation I think this has been
service we're going to let them let them
get to the bottom of this and see what
happened I'm just not going to get ahead
of it I'm just not
okay um a couple questions on the uh the
ruling the social media ruling from from
yesterday
um one I wonder why while the doj is
reviewing its options is there any
immediate day-to-day impact on the
administration's activities here at the
White House's activities so we've been
very we've been uh very kind of
consistent uh We've we are going to
continue to promote responsible actions
to protect Public Health Safety and
Security when confronted by challenges
like a deadly pandemic and foreign
attacks in our election so we're going
to continue uh to be to to do that in a
to promote that in a responsible way our
view remains that social media platforms
have a critical responsibility to take
action or to to take account of the
effects of their platforms or having to
the American people but make independent
choices about the information they
present they are private as you know
entity and it is their responsibility uh
to uh you know to to act accordingly and
so we're going to continue to be
responsible in that way but again when
it comes to this doj is reviewing the
injunction they'll do so and they'll
evaluate their options
conjunction there were a number of
people specifically named I wonder if
there is any concern about the one a
broader chilling effect of civil
servants and government employees being
unwilling to do things that may put to
you know end up with uh them being named
in a lawsuit and secondly what there's
any concern about those people who are
named facing personal harassment where
there's been any steps taken to Shield
them from that no I appreciate the
question look I'm going to let doj
manage this piece it's under uh
certainly it's under their review right
now the injection they're gonna
look I look I'm just not going to to
speak to this any further I'm just going
to let doj do their job look at their
evaluate their options and really uh
respond to this in in the best way that
they can I'm just not going to get into
individuals or employees from here
thank you Corinne just to follow up my
colleagues questions on the president
supporting Sweden's extension to Nato I
know that he has said that he supports
turkey getting f-16s but has the White
House reached out to Senator Menendez
whom I understand is still opposed to
the sale have you reached out to his
office and if you haven't are you
planning to before the villainous Summit
so I'm not going to get into private
conversations with members of Congress
you know where the president stands on
this he's been very clear when as it
relates to f-16s in Turkey just not
going to get uh into uh you know private
conversation with members of Congress
and one more on Ukraine please ahead of
the summit can you just clarify the
president's latest position on providing
security guarantees to Ukraine and
explain the thinking behind not giving
Keith what it wants which is essentially
a firm yes to membership when the war
ends I just want you to clarify what the
president's thinking about in terms of
what kind of security guarantees to
provide to keep
say so say that one more time when the
war ends yeah so so Ukraine has has been
saying that what they want from the NATO
business Summit is a clear signal that
when the conflict ends Ukraine has a
pathway a clear pathway and timeline to
uh to membership so yours are about NATO
membership specifically correct okay but
I mean I think the the understanding is
that one of one of The Reluctant
um you know leaders in the alliance is
President Biden and I just want you to
explain uh what's behind these things
we've been very clear we're committed to
NATO's open door policy we've we've been
very clear about this when when this
question comes up in the briefing we've
been very clear and have have said uh
have been showed our commitment this is
a commitment that we've had for some
time right as it relates to Nato any
decision on NATO membership is between
the 31 allies and aspirin country and so
in this case when it comes to Ukraine we
have been discussing with our NATO
allies in Ukraine how we can Collective
collectively support Ukraine's as per
operation for euro-atlantic integration
but I'm not going to get into details
I'm not going to get into private
conversations from here and the
president has said he has said this over
and over again Ukraine would have to
make reforms to meet the same standards
as any NATO country before they join he
said this thinks he thinks that this can
be do can can be done that Ukraine can
do that so I'm not going to get ahead of
private conversations from here but
again we we are committed and we have
been committed to NATO's open door
policy and we will continue to do so
yeah Sebastian thank you do you have any
uh comments or confirmation on there was
a report in the Wall Street Journal that
the U.S is looking to restrict Chinese
access to cloud computing yeah we don't
have anything else to on top of that uh
to add don't have anything new to add on
that yeah
follow up to um
how worried December 5000
describe the level of
so look look this is something that
we've as you know been monitoring we've
been very clear about how we seize
Russia's involvement here uh when when
it comes to occupying the nuclear plant
we think it is incredibly dangerous and
there should be no fighting there that
is something that we've said over and
over again it will continue to monitor
monitor we have not seen anything new to
the reporting that has been laid out
just don't have anything else to share
on this obviously we think it's
dangerous we've been very clear about
that
okay
thanks green a recent Gallup poll shows
that only 31 percent of Americans have
confidence in the US government is that
number concerning to the administration
at all what's
what the president focuses on is how
he's going to continue to deliver for
the American people that's the
president's focus in the last two years
we've seen the data when it comes to the
economy doing just that
and you know when people asked us why
we're talking about bionomics now
because we understand that people the
American people need to hear from us
directly what we have been able to do
the last two years how historic it has
been how we've been able to create a
historic amount of jobs 13 million jobs
you're going to hear from the president
in South Carolina a red State a state
that again the president said he's a
president for all Americans he's going
to go right into an area for people who
didn't vote for him many people didn't
vote for him and he's going to say how
he's delivered for them when it comes to
manufacturing how we're seeing these
manufacturing companies invest and so
that's what's important we understand
that some people just don't feel it
quite yet as you're laying out a poll to
me but we're going to make sure that we
are very clear that unemployment is uh
there is under four percent which is
really important for people to know that
manufacturing jobs 800 000 manufacturing
jobs that have been created that's
really important for people to know and
so we're going to continue to make sure
that we grow in economy that leaves no
one behind and that here you know when
we talk about bionomics it's about
building an economy from the bottom up
middle out so we're going to continue to
have those conversations the president
enjoys talking directly to the American
people that's what you're going to see
from the president tomorrow and also as
we continue our invest in America Tour
as you see cabinet members crisscross
the country having those same
conversations and we think that's what's
important
go ahead okay
thank you this is a follow-up to the
comments you made at the top of the
briefing about the one year anniversary
of the Highland
shootings and the comment in a statement
that President Biden made yesterday
noting that after the tragedy
in the summer that the state of Illinois
passed an assault weapon band so my
question is
kind of imply that if only others could
replicate that Illinois has a all
Democratic Leadership Democratic
governor the state senate the super
majority Democrats the State House the
super majority Democrat Highland Park
itself even had an assault weapon ban
how would you in the wake of a
continuing number of incidents since
Parade shooting a year ago as recently
as in the last few days
what is the best strategy going forward
that the White House has in getting
anything even some incremental measure
passed so let's just be let me reiterate
um it is tragic when you see communities
uh
dealing with gun violence and the trauma
that those communities those families
have to go through and so I just want to
be incredibly sensitive to that it is
gun violence is an epidemic in our
country the president understands this
the president his heart and his thoughts
certainly are with those families and is
devastating to see devastating to see
and so obviously anytime that happens
right now it's happening way too much
you're going to hear from us and we're
going to speak to that as it relates to
what else can be done one of the reasons
that we lift up States like Illinois and
other states that have been able to get
an assault weapons ban done or get more
done as it relates to gun reform because
it's important it's important to
highlight and to show that states can
also get involved and make change in
their own State and protect their
communities protect their kids protect
people who are who are vulnerable who
are who are dying essentially because of
this epidemic so the president every
time you hear me sadly talk about gun
violence that occurred we talk about the
states who have been able to get through
either assault weapons ban or some sort
of Common Sense gun reform so we're
going to continue to do that because
there is a path there's a way for folks
to protect their communities in their
state but at the end of the day what we
will continue to say what the president
will continue to say is that republicans
in Congress need to act they have we
need need Federal legislation the
president has done more than two dozen
executive orders he has done everything
that he can we're always looking to do
more from right here in the White House
and it is time it is time that we get
something done to protect our kids to
protect to protect our schools to
protect communities protect grocery
stores to protect all of these uh
different sadly areas that we have seen
this type of gun violence so the
president's going to continue to say
that we're going to continue to use the
bully pulpit we're going to continue to
say it right here at this at this Podium
and so that is an important way to make
sure that there's action let's not
forget it's a little bit more than a
year ago after 30 years of seeing no
action right no action on gun violence
the president was able to get a
bipartisan bipartisan deal made to move
forward a little bit more on dealing
with gun violence so things can be done
executive actions legislation we just
need more
you've described uh
your concern over a Crossing line of the
Hatch Act from the podium
when you talk about the president
himself the president is not covered by
the Hatch Act how does he think about
the red lines when it comes to his use
of office to advance his political AIMS
in his re-election do you have anything
specific are there parts of the White
House that he won't use for political
activities for example like the Oval
Office or the South lawn and we saw the
previous president use the South lawn
and South Portico as a backdrop for
accepting the nomination of his party
are there red lines for the president
himself on how he'll use the office in
the white house as a backdrop for his
political so look you know the president
uh uh is proud to have restored the rule
of law uh in his administration and I
can tell you here and I can tell you now
that he will not exploit uh his uh his
office with conventions at the White
House like it was done in the last
Administration he will not do that in
his on the south lawn in his
administration I can uh I can assure you
that will not happen in this
Administration
he will not exploit he will not exploit
uh his office uh to uh for political
game in the way that we saw in the last
Administration
yeah the injunction do you plan to
change your approach to social media
policy in the wake of the Louisiana
judge's ruling a lot of it has to do
with like the pandemic which is now over
are you still taking the same approach
with social media now as you were then
and will you change them look again the
doj is uh looking at this it's under
their review they're reviewing this the
injunction so I'm not going to get ahead
of them they're going to look at they're
going to evaluate all the options so I'm
going to say that put that out there to
you at this time but look we're going to
continue to promote responsible actions
I said this moments ago that is
something that we're going to continue
to do to make sure that we protect
Public Health to make sure that there's
Safety and Security so that is something
that we're going to continue to do we do
disagree I said this earlier moments ago
we do disagree with this decision but
the doj is going to take a look at this
and they'll come up and they'll come up
and and with their own options and
evaluate this specifically do you
disagree with the judges along that this
coordination was the form of censorship
that specifically targeted conservative
speech look
disagree with the decision I'll leave
I'll leave OJ do their move forward with
their evaluating process okay
um one more on cocaine how determined is
the president to get to the bottom of
the broader legal drugs in the White
House service is getting to the bottom
and that's what matters and it's under
their purview it was the question was
how determined is the president the
president thinks it's very important to
get to the bottom of this that's why
Secret Service which is under their
purview is looking into this and they're
going to look into what happened this
weekend so the president thinks is
incredibly important to get to the
bottom of this Administration be
appealing the injection the ruling I
just said the doj is reviewing this
injunction and they're going to look at
they're going to evaluate their options
so it's for their decision to make and
then can you just respond to the judge's
accusation that each topic suppressed by
the administration was a conservative
view he had a pretty
strong statement the US government seems
to have assumed a role similar to an
orwellian Ministry of Truth can you
respond to that I'm just not going to
respond to the attorney general the
judge I'll let the Department of Justice
do that and then I know you can't talk
about 2024. there's just this is like
the sixth question I'm sorry I'll let
you go
I know you can talk about 124 but how
will this ruling impact the
administration's efforts to get its
messaging out ahead of the election I'm
just not going to speak about 2024 we
respect the rule of law and I'll leave
it there okay guys I'll see you
this week or tomorrow thank you